good morning duty
what's up dude are you ready to go on
your hike okay cute little hiking poses
see those like
are you being shy
why are you being shy
don't be shy duty
all right well
if you haven't already saw or guessed
we're gonna go on a hike today we are
back at red rock i feel like there's
just so much to see here and i can never
get enough usually when we go to red
rock you see the actual
red rock side so we're on the opposite
side of that i know there's like a lot
to red rock but we're like in the actual
um
park of it we got bonds
and that joining us
they've been staying with us for a week
and it's been so cool just having
friends
hanging out working together
lifting together so it's been so rad
they're actually leaving today
um so we just figured we would take it
slow go out for a walk
enjoy this beautiful
thing nature created
so i think we're gonna do what is called
the icebox
canyon trail i think this is where a
moderaton stolen there it's probably
what's how does the song go my part is
where uh ice box used to or ice box
where my heart used to i don't know how
he sings it but yeah he says icebox
something yeah totally not a boomer
reference i love that you're
you're in toothless the youth of right
now right do you all know what he's
talking about
that wasn't a big thing
look at him look at him
running
super cool about uncle matt
that what we've been calling him because
we just like taika to not
call
older people than him we're super
traditional ah by the first name
so yeah uncle matt up there has had nine
surgeries
on his knee has a fake knee metal knee
he rehabbed it for a couple years
and then when he was told he's never
walking again never going to be able to
do all the stuff that he he's uh ever
done he's super athletic
he proved them all wrong ran
a 20-mile
marathon
isn't that
[ __ ] inspiring
but yeah
here we are
look at that
beautiful very convenient
keep us on trail should we turn our
stairs into rock steps
that would be cool
i'm so proud of tyka
cause he's moving so fast it's crazy
it's pleasure to see them grow and move
those little legs
good job dude
you're so fast
look at this guy
this guy's kicking butt
there you go
there you go unbelievable
a couple boosters how gorgeous is this
okay we had a spill
taika right now
fell on some rocks it was just his knee
but
he's definitely milking it and it's kind
of discouraged so we're trying to
encourage him to continue the hike look
i know that we got to walk it off
the negotiations are happening as we
speak he wants to get carried papa's
like come on
we gotta we gotta keep trucking we gotta
be strong
okay if you walk up there i'll carry you
a little bit okay
we just don't want him to get used to
everyone carrying him
we want him to like
really fight through it and be like yeah
i did hit money yes it did hurt but i
think i'm okay that's what we're trying
to
that's what we're trying to instill with
the dude and he's doing great
if it was more severe of course
all of that we're carrying him we're
doing all of that stuff but we want him
to see that he can work it out himself
good job dude tough guy
wow that's tough okay i see how tough
you are he's very tough very brave found
it dude
okay no pounds
no it's because i told him if he's tough
and he's brave
then i'll carry him that way he learns
that he could be a tough guy by himself
yep good job good job chad
good job monkey
and now you guys saw
all rocky
now we're going into like a little mini
forest look at that sounds scary when i
have someone else
i love this place
so gorgeous
tyke of course is still complaining
about everything
[Music]
please everybody have a ton of kids it's
so easy
just
have a kid now
you don't lose sleep you move fast you
get to do everything you did when you
didn't have a kid yeah just have all the
kids all at once
do it i dare you
imagine okay mister show me what you got
whoa
that was amazing
how did you do
that i'm gonna do it every day could you
do it every day
let me see it'd be great like it's doing
my time whoa
you jumped that whole rock
that was amazing dude
what
wow i saw that one
watch your head
it's hard above your head okay because
yeah look above your head
yeah but use the flashlight use a
flashlight
i'm talking to you
i don't think the dog is in a cage no
one's in there we have no idea either
that's why we sent you
hello
you're our canary
oh my god
he really is
no you know
where why are you
you
can you climb up out of there
maybe maybe you can let me see i can't
you can't
i think you can oh you get this right in
the box
i love my strong my strong friends what
is that some strong man stuff it's fun
they're looking super fun
they look heavy
what rocks rocks look heavy to you
careful monkeys careful get back here
yeah whoa look at that get back here try
it
see if you can lift it up
try this one he almost farted
he almost fallen
whoa that's pretty strong
wow don't throw it where anyone is
studying
there's a technique to it right yeah
it's almost like a
special type of cleaning yeah it's weird
it's like you uh put on your heart it's
very rdl okay
just come here this way this way
and then like once you get it
watch your feet the dirty part towards
you
because i don't want that i don't want
the rock to come in and squish a little
toast
i'm going to turn your toes into a
little pancake there's a little pancakes
yeah okay
that's the picture okay
careful monkey cheetah
yeah
like men man
[Laughter]
okay so remember that rock climber shows
you
down here there's
that guy over there
[ __ ] where'd he go over there but then
we got another guy
over here
[Music]
look at that
that's amazing that little dot right
there that's him
i am a certified
100 percent
[ __ ]
uh i don't think i'll ever do that
[Music]
okay i'm lying i don't know i never know
if i get introduced to it i might try it
i'm still a [ __ ] though
we came back from the hike and of course
my bra got cold so that canyon that we
were hiking is called ice box
and it actually made you really cold huh
yeah it was really cold look at this
lucky cheeto this guy is living the life
so me and my bear
eating our food back on the meal preps
trying to get a little bit leaner while
we balance off the crazy breakfast
oh my god that's
it's all in here baby
but yeah that's how we balance so we
have one bad meal one good meal
and this guy's living the life because
he lays on mama's lap while we feed him
hey where are you going dude
you're gonna show me something where you
guys show me
hey where'd you get that
somewhere from
what's that guy's name i don't know
you do know
remember it's
what have you been teaching
[Music]
okay so i take him to class
you want to do you want to act with me
when we say bye what do we do and they
take you to school wait what do we do
and
[Music]
and then i say bye
every single time
and the teacher is always there laughing
i'm killing it with a handshake and
every week he adds a new thing so it
started off with just two kisses then it
went to two kisses two hugs two kisses
two hugs two high fives two kisses two
hooks two high fives two have uh two
chicken wings and then the yeah the face
face squishes oh my god
this guy's nice
whenever he feels like it when he feels
inspired yeah
[Music]
eight seven five
f-stop
what
one more come over here
keeps putting that
on papa's butt
and pretending he's a chinese a chinese
master
he's gotten
pogba in the butt like five times like
painfully in the butt um so we're
slowing things down now dinner time got
some grimaldi's
do this in the oven as you can see it's
super thin
so by the time it gets here it's like
really cold like it kind of feels like
you pulled it out from the fridge
and then you're letting it get to room
temperature like that's how cold it gets
so threw it in there
oh i didn't even read the
reheat instructions but we did it right
about to eat it
go ahead go get that plate
pizza dude pizza pizza whoa
oh
oh
oh no
on that note folks
i'm gonna end it here thank you so much
for watching
have a blessed beautiful day see you
guys tomorrow